HAOHSIANG LIAO: We
always tell our students
to trust their ears,
not their eyes.
That basically means that
we want them to work more
with the audio files.
So interact with the
audio files for DVDS.
Work with them.
Work with the sounds.
And I always ask my students,
when you interact with people,
what are you dealing with?
You deal with sounds, not texts.
So that's what we mean by
trust your ears, not your eyes
because students,
when they're out
of time, the first thing
they do for preparation
is to read the dialogue.
It's reading.
They read the dialogue and
thought that they know.
However, they're not
familiar with the sounds.
And in class, what
we do a lot in class
is interactions by
speaking and listening.
So they will feel
totally disoriented
if they just focus on reading
or talking about the text
or romanizations of a language.
So that's always the first
challenge for our students,
how to give up
yourself to your ears.
And we know that this also
increases students' anxieties
from time to time.
But this is always a reminder we
have to our students every day
that work more.
When you have time, work with
the audio files, not just
reading the romanizations.
If your preparation
lies mostly in reading,
that will not get you too
far in your Chinese studies.